okay let's get this show on the roads
see if everything's going if people can
see me
and hear me and you know what i forgot
my hair is still up
ah there we go
uh it's getting out on my face to put
makeup on because
the heck with it might as well
ah okay get that going
all right so i think
i am okay with that
angle that is am i gonna keep juddering
the camera
i might oh well i think we're just gonna
have to deal
so how's it
how's everyone who isn't me cause me
oh boy
it's water
that's my story and i'm sticking to it
uh
so yeah
no longer employed hi everybody hi
randomness ms
miss wicked wolf but boy people really
aren't gonna believe that that isn't
booze now as i slur my way through
everything
the toreador in the uk thanks thank you
very much
um oh you got bad news too i'm
like honestly i feel like this has
been a universally bad day because i'm
not the only person i know
who was dealt some version of
bad news today so
yeah it seems to be an ongoing thing has
your bottle of water been saved for a
special occasion like this
yes yes it has what was your job okay i
suppose i can talk about my job a little
bit more openly although i'm still not
gonna
name the company um
i get paid tomorrow subscribing to the
patreon oh thank you i'll
i'll come back to the patreon in a
minute so um
my job uh preferred pronouns i'm
indifferent
so whatever makes sense in your head um
i worked in sales i worked the company
that i was just laid off from i was at
for nine and a half years
and i started there in customer service
and after a year they moved me to what
was called inside sales now the company
that i worked for made it oh
goodness thank you gabe uh the company
that i worked for
um made a fairly wide variety of things
and they were sold in a fairly wide
variety of
types of stores and a lot of the a lot
of the stuff was available in
you know really big chain stores like
walmart cbs
um you know things like home depot
things like that
but there were because it was a business
that had started local
it had also accumulated over time tons
of small accounts and my job was
basically managing those
and i've like i said i've been doing
that for
nine and a half years that said you know
the nature of the work well the nature
of the work didn't change the specifics
of the work kept changing as they kept
restructuring uh as the business was
prepped to be sold and then was sold
and there's
you know there's just a lot of uh a lot
of things that kept changing initially i
was
a um what was called a channel
specialist because we had stuff in like
drug uh stores and pharmacies and in
outdoor
chains and industrial safety and all
this stuff and we used to specialize by
channel so initially
i was in food drug and mass which is you
know grocery stores
drugstores and mass stores or places
like walmart
not that i had walmart that was too big
in account but like those sorts of
things so i was i was the inside sales
food drug mass specialist later they
made the decision
to carve it up by region
instead of by um channel which meant i
had the east coast and suddenly had to
learn
all of the outdoor channel ins and outs
i had to learn industrial which was a
side of business i didn't know at all
later i had to learn the promotional
side of the business which used to be
its completely own entity suddenly i had
to manage those
so i had to keep learning all this new
stuff
while at the same time that they were
going through these kinds of changes
they
repeatedly um
the polite way to say it would be uh
they restructured
my commission rate the not polite way to
say it would be they screwed me over
year over year like by a lot
um never changing my base annual
salary actually technically giving me
merit increases that in absolutely no
way offset
the massive slash to
my commission that they kept doing year
over year
so i'm not exactly sorry to not be there
anymore you know they they
did their initials screwing over of me
almost
three years ago now about two and a half
years ago where they restructure my
commission
in such a way that basically cost me
fifteen thousand dollars year over year
yeah 20s from 2017 to 2018
i lost 15 000 in annual pay
and then they restructured my pay again
and it didn't cost me
that much but it cost me more again
so again i'm not exactly sorry to not be
there anymore
and like i i want to be clear for the
time being
i'm okay i've filed for unemployment
i do have some savings i'm not
i'm not going to be destitute at the
drop of a hat my daughter's fine
um but you know a lot of how things
move forward is going to be heavily
dependent on how the next
i would say few months go
um because basically one of
a couple of things um
is gonna happen because i i am gonna
start looking for work
um so
i i figure there's a couple things that
can happen
one i could find another full-time job
which
basically and i do see the the super
chess piling up i'm gonna get to them i
promise
um i option one is i get another
full-time job which basically puts me
back where i was
in terms of the amount of time that i
have available to do the channel and the
other things that i'm trying to do
um and so that's option one
if i can find one option two the pie in
the sky
option would be if i can
if with the time that i now have
devoted to say finishing off the book
getting an audio book recorded for
skirting gender making that available
and basically
opening up more revenue streams that i'm
a between that and cutting expenses
that i might be able to just barely
scrape by
with what i make for my creative
endeavors that's a long shot
the happy medium would be i get
i build things up so that i'm making
almost what i need and then get
part-time work
um i'm not at a point where that that
third one is
viable yet i think that's the more
realistic goal
um but but we're gonna see i've like
i've made i've made a workday plan
um that i'm gonna start running going by
until
i um
until i um
you know get a get a sense of things or
get a new job so you know
spending so much time in the morning
writing and so much time
you know either shooting or pl or uh
doing active planning for new videos or
editing and you know
so i'm gonna i'm going to i'm not
sitting on my butt
it is my direct and deliberate intent
to basically between now and when i get
a job
to live as if this is paying my bills
and to schedule my day
around at that premise
so i'm gonna catch up on some super
chats here
thank you gabe up to my patreon giving
five dollars to ten dollars
and here's another twenty for your new
freedom hoping you can just work
this job and it makes you really
comfortable thank you so much like the
i i i'm not gonna lie i expected a
slight
bump in things when i when i put up the
video today
explaining that i've lost my job i
didn't expect what's happened so far
i've got dozens of new supporters
on patreon and a quite a
substantial amount i mean like your
folks are seeing the super chats but
also like one-off
um bits of support sent to my paypal and
it in a in a volume and a size that i
was not
expecting like a lot of people like gabe
also upped
their support on patreon if they were
already supporting me which
here's the funny thing i'm in a better
mood
right now than i was when i woke up this
morning
i woke up this morning it was almost
pitch dark out because it was
dark clouds and thunder and normally i
like thunderstorms but waking up to it
first thing in the morning and it was
pouring rain and i found out that i had
to go into the office turns out
so that they could fire me but i didn't
know that at the time um you know
preparing to go into the office i was in
a
foul mood this morning and i didn't
think i was even gonna do the live
stream
and i'm actually in a much better mood
now largely bolstered by
the outpouring of support both moral and
financial
so that's been that's done a lot
it it really has
so let me get to some of these other
super chats these things are coming in
so fast i can't promise i'm going to get
to questions that aren't
attached to super chess i will try um
wait don't you do burlesque as a job too
well
uh two things about that burlesque is a
live performance
so right now no because none of the
venues are open
and number two
unless you are at the absolute upper
echelons of burlesque
you don't make a living doing it because
what it costs you to put your costume
together
is probably more than you will ever make
performing the number
unless like it is legitimately your job
like you are
performing four shows a week and touring
and like being the featured guest at
festivals unless you're at that level
you don't actually make money during
burlesque burlesque is a passion
and if you're very lucky you can break
even doing it
uh sorry about your unemployment how is
your daughter holding up um
i haven't she's with her mother right
now um so i actually haven't had the
chance to talk to her mother knows
you know i've kept her uh abreast of all
this
i haven't talked to my daughter yet i'm
gonna see her tomorrow so
uh i love that conversation then um
but i i'm not too worried about her
largely because she doesn't really have
a reason to be
worried i do think things are going to
be okay
whether it's because i
you know i i'll find another job where i
get things going i do
trust that things will be all right one
way or the other
people assume that i don't know
what they know and actually i know that
they don't know what i know
[Music]
i know or do i
uh oh thank you tracy
i'm so sorry uh to hear what happened
you shouldn't be sacked and look
and look as fabulous as you do right now
ah thank you
puts my clout glasses on you
thank you amanda uh just a mini top up
to what i sent today with love thank you
very much
speaking of payments how much would i
have to pay you to make and sing a
doctor who rap
um given the financial situation i've
been
i might actually be willing to
uh to price that for you are is this
something you've already written and
just want me to do or are you
trying to commission me to write and
perform the
like honestly hit me up by email
if you're serious i mean if it's a joke
that's fine too
but if you're serious hit me up by email
we'll figure it out
um i know it's not much but i hope it
helps thank you
uh little nerdy birdie have you seen the
snl sketch where adam driver
is a part of a neo-confederate group
vermont has a big part in it oh i have
seen that
it's been a while though like i do
remember that vermont was like a thing
in that but i i don't really remember
how that worked now
uh thank you aongas
probably butchered that apologies um
how are you and your family we're okay
we're doing okay oh thank you edward
again
have you watched the expansive so what
are your thoughts if not do you have any
interest in watching it
i've not seen it i've heard enough
people recommend it that it's one of
those
maybe if i ever get around to it shows
um
and it is my hope that i now am
basically going to be taking
you know until i get other work i'm
basically going to be taking an eight
hour work day and devoting it to
video production and largely catching up
on commissioned reviews because i'm way
behind on those
if and when i actually catch up on all
that stuff i
might have time for things like the
expanse or
or avatar the last airbender which i
still haven't seen and
all that sort of thing
uh let's see 15k
in lost wages that sounds bad did you
ever suspect discrimination on the job
uh if you were open about being gender
fluid so
here's a funny thing i'd actually
already shot a video
for the vera wild channel talking about
my coming out at work coming out kind of
in quotes
um which isn't out yet i'm gonna have to
add an addendum at the front
end that i actually am not employed
anymore but the story will
will still the thing was the time that
they
slashed my pay for that i wasn't out
at work and i
here's the thing i'm pretty sure they
cut my co-worker as well
oh which is worth clarifying the
official on paper reason
was that my position was eliminated due
to
the need to cut expenses in the business
because of
covid 19's effect on revenue that's the
official reason for my dismissal
i strongly suspect um at least one
if not three of my co-workers in my
department were also
let go so i don't suspect
that this was why they let me go
um i know a lot of folks
kind of for lack of a better term
aggressively
ignored this like didn't bring it up to
the point that it's like yeah you're
making a statement by saying nothing
like because i'm standing here and i've
got
i've got a visible bust and lipstick
and this hair and uh
yeah nope no thoughts nothing
that's not to say that i go in trying to
look abrasive or anything but i mean
come on
uh when i get my first paycheck uh and
after i give a hundred dollars to my dad
uh and pay for audible i'll start 10
bucks on patreon oh
thank you uh like seriously only if you
can afford it do not
i know things are hard for lots of
people do not stretch yourself
trying to save me i appreciate all this
so much but like
be sure if you're going to support me be
sure you can afford it
that said like literally any amount
helps like even a dollar a month on the
patreon helps and any
amount in the super chats it helps it
all helps
um if you need to take a break from
youtube to get your job we understand
i i mean right now i don't i just need
to start sending my resume out
so i do need to brush up my resume
though um because like i said i haven't
i haven't had to send it out for almost
10 years
uh i really hope no one is spoiled misty
box set too because it's amazing hope
you enjoy it they haven't
i don't know what i'm going to get to it
now because i'm i'm on a spending freeze
now i i am not
um i'm not buying anything
for the foreseeable future
because i've got my existing expenses
thank you jesse
my husband was laid off eight years ago
managed to get another job within a few
months
thank you pirates um do you like
dear evan hansen i feel like i've heard
that
phrase or name or whatever before i
don't know what it is
um thank you kathleen
um they i too have been in financial
hell
uh hence no paints but i
was helped recently and wanted to share
thank you you are the first to show me i
could be genderfluid and that means a
lot oh
oh oh geez
uh i wish i could help through patreon
you deserve every dime coming your way
thank you
um oh hang on
backing up the stupid chat keeps
wanting to jump down uh to the end on me
i hope you enjoyed your anniversary by
the way i did i did listen
this year i swear so
originally liz and i were going to go to
provincetown
um for our anniversary this year
that did not happen um but we did
we went on we went on a nice hike i put
some pictures up of that and the
in the community feed and um you know we
just we spent a long weekend together
which
was nice so yeah i had i
i had a very low key but a nice
anniversary
uh with liz you're a love thank you
carolyn
send is sending you uh
support and a heart and oh god
all you folks you are wonderful suddenly
oxygen looks even more relevant
it'll be interesting to get to that one
see the thing is like i've
uh i've been capitalism critical for a
while
and and very specifically my major beef
is the investment side of capitalism
like money for goods and services
i i i'm not gonna say there's nothing
wrong with that but like i can kind of
get behind that
where i've seen things
just be awful is in investment
capitalism the need to please investors
the need for businesses to always grow
basically the company that i worked for
it was started as this small
almost you know sort of family-owned
business and it became something bigger
and at the time i came in the original
owner
had already sold it but the guy who
owned it was
growing it with the intention of selling
it to
someone with more money which he
eventually did that said he had been
with the company under its original
order
owner for a while so he did preserve
some of the you know that smaller feel
but as soon as we were actually in the
hands of of an actual investment group
yeah you could you could see
i like i i know in detail the
bull crap that happens in the name of
growth because growth is more important
than anything
meeting your growth expectations is more
important
than stability internally it is more
important than
employee satisfaction it is more
important
than quality of the product all that
matters is growth
if you can cut any of those things if
you can
cut employee benefits and you can cut
the quality of the product and you can
make this a less pleasant place to work
but it increases your rate of growth
that is what is going to happen when you
have investors
you know and i say that and one could
argue that
like my patreon supporters are kind of
investors except they're not expecting
money in return
like i i need to i need to meet their
expectations with with the product that
i produce
but i don't actually have to screw
anybody over
to make more money year over year
anyways
i saw your star wars dance cannot say
how i felt mainly due to it being kind
of weird
i'm assuming you mean my my sith
burlesque number
that was a fun one there's a like i've
got a few nitpicks about it but i i was
pretty happy with that the the lighting
uh effect of that with the lightsaber
worked really well i was really happy
with that
uh you they were screwing you over
you're better off without them
and you're now world famous youtuber you
win woo um
like here's the thing like i said i
haven't really enjoyed my job for a
while
and i truth be told i never loved it
i was fine with it for a while
but um like towards the end
i was not enjoying it particularly but
the thing was i i couldn't quit
um because i i
if you quit you can't get unemployment
and i didn't have other work lined up
so but my position was eliminated
i was laid off i do get unemployment
while i'm looking for other work
so
is asked to do a doctor who rap yeah
okay
i kind of did there didn't i i don't
know who i'd be embarrassing more
me or just the very concept of doctor
who fandom
job hunting is really draining for how
little happens and how long you have to
wait well i've been on the job hunt
before this won't be my first time in my
life
being unemployed it has been a while
though
just remember i need to check out the
far escape podcast you and jesse gender
do love that show recently re-watched it
please do
um the podcast is doing uh pretty well
i'm i'm really happy with that
um sorry to hear about your unemployment
uh have you seen snow peers for the tv
years i have not uh you know you know
now someone's mentioned it i actually
kind of want to see this doctor who rap
uh do you think 13's look could be based
off
rose jody kind of looks like rose and as
jack is more likely to be in the special
they pick up the idea and doctor can
base their face on people
i don't see it like the only resemblance
is that they're both blonde
no sorry i don't see it at all
i'm making this series and one of the
characters names everyone
seems to pronounce differently just
curious how you would say the name
see i would go back and forth as to
whether that is eradia
or aradia um
i would probably go with a radia because
that
like sounds better to my ear uh and my
sensibilities
so is that how it's supposed to be
i don't know uh maybe we should have
council geeks and jesse
just gender do a who trek rap battle
[Laughter]
oh what a hot mess that would be just
watch the cabin in the woods gotta say
it's my second favorite
horror movie uh if you're curious tucker
and dale versus evil is mine
uh i am not a big fan of eve
there are of those i like the
concept of tailin of uh tucker and dale
versus the
tail and ducker tucker and dale versus
evil
the execution i didn't love i like
everything that wasn't
them the two of them i was like
and cabin in the woods i just hate the
ending
i hate it so much i think it was the
first movie i ever did
a good movie bad ending video on
i haven't done one of those in a while
it's so beautiful seeing all these
people supporting their fellow geek
and the trying time the world can feel
like it's ending it
uh it helps to see fellow geeks come
together for support it
honestly yeah it helps a lot
i was actually around your daughter's
age when my dad lost his job
uh took him a couple years before he got
hired by honda
where he worked until he retired due to
illness hmm
i'm glad he did manage to find something
i lost my job in may due to covid budget
cuts i feel you're paying yeah
a lot of people would the backlog of fan
submissions be covered by any of the
current patreon tears because it's
something i'd be interested in helping
out with
um i'm not entirely sure i understand
the question there
i mean like the i've just got a i've
just got a lot of
commissioned reviews that i'm overdue on
i mean there'll be one
going up um
thursday because i don't i don't like to
do uploads to the break room and here on
the same day so that'll go up thursday
and that one's
like seven months overdue um i'm
a ways behind information you have
one question left
nice reference edward i like it uh
hang in there uh thank you comp girl
last year i was in the same boat i
finally found work just as covet hit and
it was scary but it all worked out and
i'm back working
it will work out in the end for you
thank you i appreciate that
uh i have a visible bust vera 2020 well
i do i mean jeez
this this is unassisted
there's nothing there but me
um thank you ben this is a
filthy this is filthy brit coinage but i
hope it helps
your money spends just as well as
anybody else's
thank you cara uh what a time to be laid
off i'm sorry here's a little boost to
my patreon pledge
keeping your fabulous self thank you so
much
all right i gotta back up again because
the chat jumped
down on me here we go
dieter evan hansen is a musical oh okay
i have heard of it thinking of
re-watching clone wars favorite
episodes i haven't watched it so
no opinion um
[Music]
i have no patreon subs right now we'll
be summing you on friday oh
i'm personally offering jobs to anyone
interested how do you feel about
assassination work
what's the pay rate and then do i do i
get discretion uh like is this
is this a gig or is there a retainer
involved
look email me we'll figure it out
be sure to add accepts doctor who themed
wrap commissions to your resume
i'm not putting anything on my resume
until till
we see how much of a disaster
it is uh
yeah resumes are weird i have basically
no work experience because i've been in
education
since i was five so i'm paid
to look for work but very few people
uh physical chemist not sure what that
means at the tail end of that i don't
know if there was a typo
hugs thank you to quote something often
said about doctor who on this stream
and say it uh about who buffy should
have chose
it's never riley uh
i don't have any source of income but
here's some holy
chicken nuggies gives you chicken
nuggies thank you random movie and
uh
uh have you seen the video where peter
capaldi talks about surrealism basically
a history lesson with the doctors you
teach it's great i haven't
i'm going to look that up now well not
now but
as a result of that i will look back up
dear evan hansen is a musical that had
broadway a year after hamilton came out
so it didn't get the attention it
deserved
it's about mental illness and how social
media makes it worse ooh
sounds good but sounds heavy after all
the hours of entertainment insight into
lgbt and honestly you can't
uh use the the word so uh fantastic
dance is the least i can do a spare ten
dollars
thank you
uh did you read the ballot of songbirds
and snakes if so are you going to do a
review
i haven't cause i'm not even sure what
that is
happy anniversary thank you rebecca
games used to be designed in a way that
uh
that they survived the bomb during a war
now they can break if you drop them on
the ground
i mean that's not new though
ever since games went to disk
i listened to an audio circular time it
made me get the
fifth doctor i recommend it but aside
from your situation
i'm worried i've drink i've changed it
for you now and you and you still won't
get him
oh we'll see i just noticed how much you
love pirate stuffy even your water
bottle looks like a whiskey bottle
um you'd find on the beach this was
this was from the basha kill vineyard so
this was
uh this was uh originally a wine bottle
now it just has water officially
are you familiar with the south korea
film called old boy oh
yes yes i am
i'm familiar with old boy i've seen i've
seen the entire vengeance trolls you
have seen sympathy for mr vengeance oh
boy and
lady vengeance um they're all very good
can you sing a song from hamilton uh no
cause this uh
the video will get demonetized when i
archive it if i do that
well if i do much of it anyways
um besides which i don't know any of the
songs well enough
like maybe
you'll be back wait and see
you remember you belong to me
you'll be back and i gotta stop there
uh what are you planning about school
for your daughter uh what they're doing
for schools here is they're doing kind
of a hybrid
of both at home and in school learning
basically they're having
kids on this variant schedule so that
there aren't that many kids in the class
at the same time so some kids in the
class some kids at home
rotating them in and out i think it's
actually kind of staggered so it's not
just the same kids
so they all get to see each other i'm
not entirely sure it's working but it's
a hybrid
plan is what is what they're doing
off topic or is it have you seen uh
peter capaldi's
oscar-winning short franz kafka it's a
wonderful life
from 1993 that he directed i haven't but
i did know that he got an oscar for that
billionaires shouldn't exist agreed
uh you get to drink a slushy slurpee
with a doctor
who do you pick and what flavor or color
do you pick seems as you i'm guessing
it's something with water in it
um liz has a friend who makes
mead slushies
and uh i i could knock that back with uh
with the 12th doctor i think
uh i don't want you to do a doctor who
rap i want you to watch doctor in
distress
and then sing it drunk i'm guessing it
will cost me millions
i'm not i don't know doctor in distress
but i have a hunch
it's not pleasant have you started
harley quinn season two not yet
who versus track rehab battle which
captain mess
the most with time 11 versus that
captain
you could have captain captain jack
versus captain kirk
that's that's sort of my immediate if
you're going to do verses there
that character's name is going to be a
running joke where everyone
pronounces it different and you never
actually find out the right way
i kind of like that i also saw capitol
woods got excited so i could finally
watch your bad ending video i
respectfully disagree even though i'm
lukewarm on the end of myself
fair fair enough
uh if theaters are open when it comes
out hopefully the november date will
stick will you go to see no time to die
anything else uh anyone else in the chat
as well
i hope it gives craig a good end i mean
all the things that were supposed to
come on the theaters i will still see
eventually whether it's in the theaters
or streaming
um i i don't know what it's going to be
like
come november if that date even holds
uh has your daughter ever been in your
videos
um sword of
there's i think one video where
i forgot to cut out her
coming in and asking me something and
another where i like stuck a little bit
on the very end post credits
but those were you hear her voice
she has never visibly appeared on this
channel and she won't
um not until she's at an age where i
feel confident that she understands
the consequences of appearing in a venue
like this
because at her age i don't trust that
she would understand what that would
even mean
i would have to i would have to know and
trust that that
she would um be comfortable doing this
and would understand the possible impact
it would have
and even then only if she wanted to
which she might
not want to anyways so
no she's never visibly appeared mermaids
are unicorns oh
that's actually really tough i guess i
can't
i have a i have a uh a very good friend
who has been sending me
a um a lot
of let's go with
um enticing mermaid art
um that like she's been finding so like
i'm kind of leaning toward mermaids
right now
uh let's see
uh have uh you have to use tim curry's
famous command and conquer line about
capitalism
and space as the open for your oxygen
re-review i would have to look up
what those apparently famous words are
because i don't know them
good vibes here's hoping this is the
start of something really good thank you
tracy
your thoughts on spc
don't use abbreviations because i don't
i'm really bad
at keeping track of abbreviations and
acronyms i don't know what spc
is sorry alastair you don't have to
super chat again to
to clarify like just at me and i'll try
to answer it
uh you really didn't like a girl not
killing a friend to save the world and
then getting high
while saying how much humanity sucks and
having ancient gods killing everyone
no i didn't like the fact that it was
not framed as an atrocity the fact that
they did that because
it was like i talked about this in
i i've done a i've done an entire
video uh on this my problem is if you're
going to end the world
whether or not i'm going to be okay with
that depends on how much the world you
establish
so like a movie that effectively ends in
the end of the world
that i like is dr strangelove but a big
part of why that works
is that the world as you see it
is just all these military jackasses
so even though it's the whole world and
theoretically everyone who lives in it
you only ever see
these morons so for the purposes of the
film
that's the world that's getting
destroyed and screw them it's their
fault
the problem i have with cabinet in the
woods the reason that ending doesn't
work for me
is because they establish
children they establish
children they establish innocent people
they establish
too much about the world outside of
these victims and the people in the in
this facility if they hadn't done that
i probably still wouldn't have loved the
ending but it wouldn't take me off
and again this is partly parental uh
instinct kicking in but
if you're going to casually destroy the
world including
the established children of the world
that you have been sure to make clear do
exist uh screw you
um we were talking about cabin in the
woods in case didn't know i should have
given a spoiler warning
it's an old movie how will it um
good luck and thank you for showing me
an example of adult gender fluidity
it helps me find uh comfort in the label
seize the means
thank you uh to quinqua
to kinka i i'm not again names
pronunciation not always my strong suit
moulin rouge are the greatest showman oh
greatest showman i don't like blue long
rouge at all
i never have that movie gives me a
headache
sorry the question was unqueer what i
meant was whether the fan works
uh you've been sent would fit in to your
reward tiers where you'll watch
x episodes of a series and such oh
okay i see what you're asking now
um
i don't i don't
know what my comfort level is with
being paid money to review
works from fans and by the way i have
started reading the
the poems and the things that you sent
me i haven't gotten very far but i have
actually started
um here's the reason i'm not
particularly comfortable with the idea
of being paid to review that stuff
it's largely because i would not
guarantee a positive
review it would be my honest thoughts
and i kind of
am not comfortable with the idea of
taking someone's money and then crapping
on their work
if they are a fan of what i do or if
they are an independent creator
like i've done um
or i will have done uh on the vera wild
channel recently product reviews
um that i wasn't paid for but i was
provided the
products um that i normally would have
had to have paid for
but it was all that is being done with
the understanding like i'm going to give
my honest opinion and these are
companies i'm not going to feel bad
if they if like a company
were to commission me in some way
to review something and i would ended up
being critical
of it but individuals
i i don't feel okay doing that and
because i can't guarantee that it would
be a positive review
and also there's there's also the
potential issue
of selling my own integrity um
where it where it becomes a case of
because the the idea with the commission
reviews is you know you pay me to give
my thoughts on
on some piece of work and in theory it's
not
hugely to have to be a piece of work you
created
except that like for me that that is
enough of a shift where i'm
not totally comfortable
uh
today's international non-binary
awareness day
i raise a toast to my envy cousin
your envy cousin a toast
yes it yes happy international
non-binary awareness day
uh remember when the doctor regenerated
so hard the universe
went from black and white to color now
that was whack
i like the way you put that edward thank
you
uh best i can do is keep you on the nice
list
i'll settle for that random question any
thoughts on lindsey ellis's titanic
video was pretty good
uh you doing drag i haven't done a
traditional drag show
in a long time um so no
it's been about a decade since i've done
drag
um or if you're asking if i'm doing drag
right now in this video
no i'm just looking how i want to look
ballad of songbirds and snakes is a
hundred oh that's the hunger games
prequel
okay i haven't read the hunger games
books i've only seen the first two
movies
so
let's see the surrealism video with
peter capaldi is called exploring the
surreal of peter capaldi
cool tune of you'll be back p.o.v
tardis
pirate's very nice you'll go here
you'll go then you'll learn and you'll
have no
control you'll go where
i want to send you
[Music]
so are you a reverse jesus you turn
wine into water
[Laughter]
favorite song from hamilton the king
songs for me the king's songs are
definitely the
easiest ones to get stuck in your head
because they're slower um
i i there's a lot of good ones i liked
the king's songs i liked satisfied
um i liked what i miss
um i liked the first cabinet rap battle
and i liked the room where it happened i
don't think i can pick a single favorite
you can do a series on the break room
where you review a movie of your choice
well i mean like
anything that i've seen recently that i
feel like just talking about that just
ends up on the break room anyway
no no no if your daughter's school is a
hybrid plane does that mean you will
turn out to be the timeless child
[Laughter]
thank you uh louise so much support
i've been through so many financial
struggles and i understand we're here
for you thank you so much
peter capaldi walks into a school board
meeting talking about where is the
hybrid
imagine if mary poppins was 9 10 11
12 and 13's companion i figure she'd be
an occasional bit like river
makes sense
uh doesn't know the doctor in distress
no i don't i have a feeling that
there's pain involved uh
i saw a really cool impression video of
some hamilton songs he did some amazing
who impressions oh cool i've seen some
of those like there was somebody did
like the entire first act in muppet
voices which was
kind of neat but got old uh so i didn't
stick with it but
like i admired the dedication
uh the hamilton song to remind you of my
love sounds like something the master
would sing
john's sim of the missy yeah
uh have you seen the trailer for star
trek below deck i have
um i didn't love it i mean it looked
fine but it i know it's from the same
creators as rick and morty but i feel
like that style of humor is kind of
taking over
um animation not aimed to kids and i
always
especially in anything comedic i get
really nervous when a single tone
becomes
the wave of comedy and i feel like it
happens with comedy more than a lot of
other things like in the 90s
it was the wave of the fairly brothers
and really stupid
deliberately stupid comedy and then we
were
in the judd apatow phase for a long time
which i hated
you know these barely scripted the
actors are just
improving their way through scenes that
barely connect there isn't really a
story
i hate that it's not funny there's no
flow
sucks and while i don't have as strong a
distaste
for the rick and morty style of humor
um i don't love it and i don't like that
i'm starting to feel like that approach
is starting to become
the go-to comedy approach at least in
animation
and that makes me nervous if
if the 60th anniversary was a shot shot
remake of the five doctors would you
watch
it i mean yeah i'll watch it whatever it
is
i would wonder why
but have you seen
the teaser on twitter for contemporary
death
spooky stuff original two is supposed to
take
the slasher to a new level new version
of the grim reaper i don't know
slashers i'm not huge on either
oh okay hold on let me back up here
uh
all right oh boy i i am
really falling behind i was almost
catching up
uh doctor under stress is a song doctor
who did to protest being canceled during
the colin baker era none of them could
sing it's so painful oh god oh no
no no no uh have you ever heard of
waitress the musical
yes i have not heard the music from
it aside from opening up which i do know
and i like that song
just a video where a trans man and his
fiance explained to being trans
to her sisters took the sister four
minutes to get it
um were these
like the young kids
that they were explaining it to because
i if that's the video because i saw that
it actually made me really uncomfortable
yeah
because and i'm not saying this didn't
happen
but i really wish they had clearly
established in that video that they'd
gotten clearance from the parents of
these kids
to have this conversation and film it
and i don't
doubt that they did but the fact that
they didn't establish that made me
really uncomfortable watching it uh
again maybe that's just me as a parent
very
protective and very not eager to put my
kid
on camera can't believe chibnall is
going for revolution of the daleks when
we
spent many livestream coming up with
much more interesting of the dalek
titles
is he reading my emails maybe they're
going to spam
i i told you not to send one every day
good for you and your daughter
appearing on youtube too many youtubers
use their children for clicks
and i mean there's that too but i mean
for me really it's
creating a digital footprint for your
kids before your kids
have a proper understanding of what that
means
that that just strikes me really
irresponsible
like that's more than like trying to be
clickbaity
about it that is really where my
discomfort comes in imagine a daycare
with all the new who doctors
children 13 11 would just fight
as 13 would steal 11's biscuits
thank you natasha this isn't much since
my daughter's surgery is next month
but you make her smile and in turn make
me smile
wishing you the best during these times
the best of luck
to your daughter for her surgery so i'm
hoping for the best
sontara stratagem the poison sky or
under the lake before the flood both
highly ignored underrated and fantastic
in my opinion
um i really am i am going to be getting
to
review uh re watching
under the lake and before the floods and
i feel like i need to do before i can
make that call
i would lean towards that one but they
are both good
s cp is part of a creepy pasta oh
creepypastas really aren't my jam
uh have you seen parasites if yet what
did you think of it
um no i'm not yet have you seen the
theory that buffy and firefly are in the
same universe and cabin in the woods is
how
earth uh that was
got used up i did it seems like a really
big stretch
to me doctor stranger level was supposed
to end with a pie
fight in the council war room between
the generals but kubrick cut it out yeah
i'd read that too i think he made the
right call in
la la la under the greatest showman
greatest showman still
my mom sat me down for a serious talk
today she told me i was the timeless
child i'm pissed off now
what do you think of a regeneration and
post regeneration done as one story the
doctor regenerates halfway through
maybe in a mini series format no
no i don't think that's a good idea i
think you should give
you know the outgoing doctor a full
story to
give a send-off and give the next doctor
full breathing room to
take their place no i i would never
recommend doing that
do you enjoy this song knock on wood i
don't know if i know that
song or at least if i do i don't know
that i don't know by name
i ordered 150 tongue painter lollipops
off amazon
hold on i just lost um
are 150 tongue painter lollipops on
amazon
do you think i have a problem
if you're doing something other than
licking them like yes
and if you're doing like 20 a day
yes other than that if it makes you
happy
um i totally understand the hesitation
and can see how that would be awkward
thanks for explaining yeah
no it's not a problem yeah thanks for
clarifying the question so i was able to
answer that
with my novels i pay people to crap on
them
well suggest how to make them better
well that's called editing
that's called hiring an editor like i i
i got a first editing pass back in my
book and
like it some some of the um
uh some of the things that i read was
like oh
oh but they were all good notes
a lot of which i'm i'm working on taking
into account but yeah
with all the gender politics we have now
do you think we're at a point where
biological sex and gender identity
should be separated personally i do
they are separated
they they always have been they've never
been the same thing
it's just that only recently is the
majority of the populists
being made familiar with concept
that they're not the same thing and it's
a hard thing for a lot of people to wrap
their heads around
because for the majority of the
population
their biological sex and their gender
identity
are the same thing and wrapping your
head around people for whom it is
not the same thing is
tricky and difficult and it can be hard
to
um to make sense but something i want to
be really clear about
especially because certain
uh certain
individuals spouting their thoughts on
uh
transness who i am uh trying really hard
to not think about it
right now uh keep putting forth this
idea that
gender identity is either the not
the denial or the obliteration of
biological sex it's not
acknowledging gender identity is not
saying that biological sex does not
exist or that it doesn't matter
it's treating them as different things
because they are
so anytime anyone
talks down trans rights
by saying biological sex is real
no kidding it's real if biological sex
wasn't real trans people
wouldn't have to pay through the nose
for hormone and surgery for gender
reassignments
no trans person that i have ever met
thinks that
biological sex isn't real
so that entire thing
using that as as a as a rallying cry
against trans people that biological sex
is real
yeah nobody said it wasn't
we're talking about something else
i hate that i hate that kind of i hate
those kinds of cowardly tactics
where it's like okay can we talk about
this but this
that's not what we're trying to talk
about but this
i'm not even disagreeing with you but
that's not what we're talking about over
here we're trying to have this
conversation but this
get that look off my chest can you end
the video saying my cavity again if i
remember
we'll see thank you brayden i love your
hair and the things you do love your
doctor who videos you're so cute
i hope things get better hope this tiny
bit helps it does
thank you allow me to be frank i'm not
really into doctor who i'm more
interested in your other videos on other
entertainment subjects
fair um and those videos are
gonna start being a bit bigger in a bit
a more elaborate strong way to put it
but i'm getting more ambitious with the
non-doctor who videos
um or at least trying to what episode of
doctor who springs to mind when you
think about episodes you like but no one
else does i mean
one of the ones that i really enjoy that
a lot of people don't seem to care much
for
is a robot of sherwood so
and that's that review is coming up soon
uh for the lords of the sea
well technically next to the sea oh
discord thank you carowind um
and if you've reminded me again since
then uh
apologies i am like way behind in the
chat to score discord discord haha
here we go so uh reminder
discord is the patreon part which there
are dozens more of you
with access to that now so
enjoy and welcome um let's see
i can't seem to find an appropriate or
inappropriate
oprah gift for the occasion you get
unemployment
you are unemployed and everybody's
unemployed
lovely um let's see
how many times do you have to wat uh did
you have to watch hamilton to get
the bullet um
apparently i didn't get it fully i've
seen it twice i had not
caught that one of the um
members of the ensemble was was
literally meant to represent
the bullet and death as a harbinger
throughout the entire show
i had to google and find that out
so um two viewings and a google
uh let's see not a question but some
support sorry about your unemployment
best of luck with job hunting thank you
very much
um i find it very hard to make to the
streams but i'll try
now it's fair uh not a question but that
video
where your daughter made the accidental
cameo was your hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy video
saw for the first time fairly recently i
decided to bite the bullet
and give it a read thanks for
introducing me to my new favorite book
yes uh
jelly beans or jelly babies i'm gonna
say jelly beans
somebody sent me jelly babies a couple
years ago i didn't love them
i mean they were okay i did eat them but
they weren't
great um
what do you think about how overblown
nude who generation
regeneration is uh classic literally had
a scene transition
knew who they have the power to destroy
a dalek fleet it started with nine
saying um don't be right next to me when
i regenerate and i guess spiraled out
from there
well okay so
there are in universe reasons
why they've gone the way they have to an
extent
so like with eleven it's not
that a regeneration is inherently
explosive it's that
he was granted an entire new
regeneration cycle
by the time lords when he was supposed
to be done
so now everything with the timeless shop
makes this all mode not make sense
anymore like they shouldn't have had to
do that
especially if the time lord's like new
but anyways hey
at the time he was granted a whole new
regeneration cycle which wasn't supposed
to happen which made the whole thing
much bigger and so that i was okay with
the the general premise of the turret is
always crashing and or blowing up
every time they do a regeneration i
don't like there was no real reason for
it to blow up when tenant regenerated
there um was no real reason for
everything to go haywire after 12
regenerated
you know i i don't i don't care for that
all right popping back over
uh if you reviewed anything i've written
i want your honest opinion even if you
think it's awful
it showed me how i could fix it or if it
can be fixed at all but that's just me
again like i i lack the free time
to give feedback to to things that
people just send me
um i like i i try
i do my best but i don't guarantee how
long it'll take me to do it it could
take me months
at best like it's taking me months to
get the stuff people are actually paying
me to review
it's it's just i wouldn't uh and i'm
happy to give honest feedback i
i don't i don't i'm not i don't have so
much of a filter that i wouldn't give
you honest feedback i just
feel bad about taking your money to
to do it um like
like i said it if you're paying an
editor or something that's one thing but
like you'd effectively be asking me to
beta read
your stuff and you shouldn't have to pay
beta readers
if if you didn't know that like you
shouldn't
have to pay beta readers that doesn't
mean that it's a scatter shot and
people may or may not get back to you
but it
yeah you pay people to edit
uh at least that that's
my understanding of of the beta reading
process
i guess there are some people who like
do it professionally but that's usually
people who beta read and spend in like
certain genres
or to look at through certain um lenses
so that's almost like um you're getting
uh
a sensitivity reader or or uh or things
like that
and that's different like that you
should pay people for but
i don't know i'm diverting on that
uh happy non-binary day officially came
out
online which was fun oh congratulations
tried to explain people feeling genders
as like people identifying with their
blood type
that's interesting um thank you
randomness favorite song from once more
with feeling i
am i like rest in peace but i
probably go with walk through the fire
part of the reason i like rest in peace
is because it's in my range so
let me rest in peace
have you heard congratulations angelica
song cup from hamilton i have not
disney uh television animation has been
on a roll lately in fact two of their
best shows amphibia and the owl house
just came back from hiatus i have not
heard of either of those
when's your next classic who review
later this week
uh that's in the break room mesmerized
by the lava lamp oh
thank you i think you might actually be
the first person to mention the dang
thing
um thanks for explaining that helps
clara up a lot for me thanks for taking
a look at my work oh
thank you and thank you thank you for
the support since he was a mixture of
time lord and cybermen and he destroyed
gallifrey the master was the hybrid oh
forgot it's like this
freaking hybrid thing ah
cobia 19 isn't real i just figured it
out liz is using the reality stone on
her infinity gauntlet so people stay
inside and read more
books so when it's over they go to her
library
that's that's an interesting conspiracy
theory
since you like drag i think that if you
were to come over to the uk
in december you should go to watch a
pantomime with your daughter get a taste
of it on youtube
um see the thing is like i
i fell into drag initially by default
because i
i'm a performer by nature huge surprise
and as i was exploring my femininity
drag was a natural way to do that but as
soon as i found burlesque
i moved away from drag i don't connect
with it
as strongly as as an art form
a new sandman on audible uh got to ask
for a patreon boost for the
sign up and uh
to go for it nice word al did a hamilton
polka i know
i i linked to it in the community feed
i'm glad i'm not the only one regarding
comedy trains oh
good i'm glad i'm not the only one i
feel i feel like old man yells at cloud
on that subject sometimes whenever i
hear hamilton i just think uh trisha
paytas singing the song
burn i believe i hope that
i'm not sure what to make of that
comment um
which is more annoying annoying biodome
or jury duty i don't know i refuse to
watch either one
so
[Music]
let's see where was i ah
oh for god's sake i really fell behind
again
i keep thinking i'm almost catching up
and i'm i'm
really not uh
jeez i may just have to give up trying
to
trying to keep up with the chat
uh do you like ricky gervais no i've
never liked ricky gervais
have you seen shiro do you plan on
watching all of it i've got multiple
video reviews up on she
on the subject of shira oh yeah i love
it i've
i've got i've got commissioned art of
scorpio right up there
doctor in distresses star wars holiday
levels are bad oh
god oh
that's that's unsettling to hear it was
a jimmy dodger video oh that's right
that was actually why i didn't subscribe
to his channel for a while
because that video made me super
uncomfortable
i have seen some of his other stuff and
i do like it a bit but like
that video made me really uncomfortable
and i actually
didn't people have recommended this
channel to me i didn't subscribe to it
for a while because of that
um also dc showcase
death specter phantom stranger sergeant
rock and jonah hex
do they have these t-shirt cases for all
those like i've seen the
spectre one i know that's actually a
thing
scp is a series of stories on their own
website ranging
from eldritch lovecraftian to cough gas
stories and bizarre fairy tales
okay
uh what's your favorite song from next
to normal ooh
[Music]
um
the the one to they they flow one into
the other who's crazy
and my psychopharmacologist and i again
partially biased because who's crazy is
in my vocal range
you may have noticed i'm partial to
songs that i can actually sing along
with
well um but
um who's crazy the the back end of it
has
i my favorite line of the show and one
of my favorite lines
uh as the last part of the song they
say love is blind but believe me
love is insane
i love that i love that line
uh may want to shake the wi-fi box a bit
as the live is a little glitchy
ah yeah i don't know what's been up with
my wi-fi lately
since doing your re-watch have any
doctors gone up or down in your
estimation not as yet
i'm writing a doctor who's story
basically the doctor goes into a
cracking time ends up in a parallel
universe
where an infection has taken over the
universe might be too zombie yeah
[Music]
yeah thank you very much while we wait
for tenant what is your favorite nolan
film and what do you think is his best
my favorite nolan film is
the prestige i think inception's
probably his best movie finished my own
re-watch
of the tenant era i didn't like the end
of time as much
even though i usually like it when
protagonists despair over the bad hand
they've been dealt with
there's a difference between despairing
and being whiny i think he kind of just
he kind of he throws a hissy fit
i don't know
you don't have a jam with creepy pasta
that would taste horrible
have you seen magicians season four
finale i haven't seen any of the
magicians um
have you heard of a musical called
shreds about jack the ripper
nope do you think it'd be cool if
whitaker's regeneration story was also
the 60th anniversary episode
no no because i would much rather
the 60th be a celebration of the show as
a whole rather than be the end of
that dark specific era uh remember the
white point stars the diamond from
gallifrey from end of time i know white
point star
according to missy um book wrassle on
regenerated because the master shoves
some down his throat ouch ooh
ooh yeah now that's um unpleasant
i think canceled culture would be more
fun with daleks and extermination
no comment uh did you watch lindsay
ellis video
about rowling i did it was
it was pretty good i don't think it was
one of her better ones but she's she's
also obviously
not used to working unscripted you can
kind of tell
not that it's bad but you can tell she's
out of her comfort zone
a bit
uh why do some people think trans people
are like davros and journeys and the
destruction
of agenda itself
oh my god a pokemon ad came on my tv
anyone remember when that was a thing oh
pokemon go my
my daughter still plays pokemon go uh if
they really believe biological sex
determine gender
i i would be accepted as intersex
non-binary
well yeah no they that's uh that's among
the topics that we just
let's not talk about that doesn't
support our thesis
um
[Music]
but this will be the next big battle and
our dream will follow up to tim shaw oh
for god's sake
uh the greatest roman era star was born
i didn't see a star is born
uh do you think tim shaw brushes his
face
like he would uh the teeth in his mouth
i don't think he would have to
uh have you ever speculated fictional
characters as time lords and who do you
think
could be a time lord i mean i i haven't
really
um done that
i like i've seen the arguments for why
santa claus is a time lord and why mary
poppins is a time lord and why james
bond is a time lord
and like they're cute but it's not
really something um
[Music]
that that i've gone in for like coming
up with my own theories
i got a job just before lockdown i was
supposed to start the day after lockdown
oh boy do you have a favorite movie
soundtrack or movie soundtrack composer
i love bond scores especially john berry
um i am really partial to
the soundtracks from the um
how to train your dragon movies i really
like the soundtrack of the first pirates
of the caribbean
i really like the braveheart soundtrack
um
i've got a video up i'm on my favorite
soundtrack
um you know uh musical scores
so search around it's it's on there
virus theme that tick tock sound bow
down you're talking to your highness
i have that bloody song stuck in my head
what do you think would happen if the
companion touched the doctor when he she
is regenerating
um
i don't know i suppose we have the risk
of
another medic crisis like with donna
when they reset the doctor
when he became heart now they use the
chameleon arch to turn him into a
biological time lord with a regen limit
hence
time of the doctor i believe is that
fannin or is that canon
um i didn't like the time lords granting
more regenerations but
this would also mean river shouldn't
have actually lost her
generation someone else um
can lay her uh i thought the tardis
exploded when terran regenerated because
he was venting nuclear radiation i've
seen that as
fan head cannon that's not confirmed in
the episode
maybe the time lords only said they were
giving him a new regeneration cycle to
avoid facing what would happen when he
regenerated
when he shouldn't have done because
timeless child i mean possibly but then
we lose the explanation as to why
it's so much bigger than a normal
regeneration
you might have missed my nolan super
chat when the discord jumped
no i was just that far behind
twenty dollars coming via paypal thank
you so much i enjoy your
reviews and uh view of forgive me if i
use the wrong term definitely not
something i'm immersed in
gay and other gender rep
without it being a clue by four
thank you very much do you think lgbtq
history has been erased would you ever
consider making
videos on lgbt history i
probably won't but just because i'm
not great at research
it history is not a topic
i'm particularly well versed in
uh nor is it one that i have a lot of
natural inclination towards so trying to
research historical stuff
is not easy for me and i don't trust my
own ability to do it well
like when i do research for videos on
the channel it's
very targeted it's based around
researching around
a specific thing like when i researched
sort of the history of rowling's you
know things she's
people she's followed liked shared
commented etc
back in december before she really
confirmed
everything like i did research for that
but it was
targeted on a specific person around a
specific topic
but that's just so broad i
i don't trust my my own ability to do
that
has lgbt has lgbtq history been erased
uh yeah yeah
erased and or obfuscated and ignored
you know the fact that people
seriously make the claim that
non-binary identities and
you know transgender and just not
straight people is somehow a
new thing i get you don't hear the
argument about
um you know
non-straight as much but certainly
with gender identity the fact that
they're
you know people's claim like that an act
like this is all new
and none of it is the only thing that's
new
is the medical ability to actually
facilitate transition
you know hormone regimens and gender
reassignment surgeries
those are relatively new the existence
of
trans and non-binary people
is not at all
i meant play her but that works
uh yeah don't worry typos they get us
all
the lava lamp matches your top oh
you're right it does that's fun
no matter what goes on now just remember
you have this massive community
that love you for you stay strong thank
you i i'm gonna
try and speed through some comments and
try and catch up because i should i
should
wrap up uh if you come to england try as
many of our suites
uh on a live as you can like i said
couple years ago somebody sent me a
whole bunch
of um
uh of uk snacks including like the king
prawn
crisps uh
um those were oh god those were terrible
and jelly babies which were
fine uh let's see
uh what's your opinion of trisha paytas
i have none
i have not looked into trisha paytas
enough to have an opinion because i
don't want to
uh so gather you wouldn't approve of
paulie shore being the next doctor
you might have missed my nolan super
chat with the discord jump
nope i got it uh richard uh
i i can never pronounce this i already
on the mighty boosh
i he he's okay he doesn't really do much
for me
owl house is a super fun animated magic
oriented
show it's a blast your daughter might
like it tons of really awesome female
characters
i'll keep i'll keep that in mind
um we're actually working on gravity
falls right now which we're both
enjoying
this has been in my mind for a couple
days how dare terrifying and awesome
grace jones would be as the master oh
like that please react to doctor in
distress on this live as i don't think
you'll
get copyrighted uh because ace creeper
reacted to it on live he didn't get
copyrighted um
maybe i'll do a reaction and put it up
in the in the break room
what are your thoughts on once upon a
time have not seen it last stream
i told you about deceased and told you
it was
dc's marvel zombies but let me clarify
it's written by tom taylor who also
wrote the injustice comics well i
haven't read those so that's not
that's neither a plus or a minus in my
book i won't listen to alan moore's
march of
sinister ducks thank you very much
douglas i appreciate that
i think it was because tennant uh did
the whining at wilf i kept yelling
apologize after tennis started getting
at him
um yeah that might that might be it
uh carrie fisher is the only person to
have an official copy of the holiday
special apparently played it when she
wanted people to leave
her house i did hear that um
[Music]
thank you douglas just remember and
thank you randomness
i just remembered uh everyone's favorite
incarnation of the master is getting his
own big finish series the one the only
eric roberts
oh boy is cue a time lord i suppose i'm
arguing could be made that the
continuum is like a branch
off of time lords i've recently got into
the world of dragon oh boy the tuck
is weird tucking takes some getting used
to
i don't really do it anymore but yeah no
i've i i did my years in the tucking
trenches
i find it so confusing when people say
being trans is not natural because we're
animals therefore we are part of nature
so surely our choices and experiences
etc are natural
i feel like it's more of an odd thing to
turn it into a debate about whether or
not something's natural
in the first place technology isn't
natural
youtube isn't natural money isn't
natural
democracy is not natural like
saying something shouldn't be allowed
because it's not natural like
literally the entire basis of human
civilization none of it is natural
so that's that's a nonsense
basis for an argument in the first place
still extremely attracted to you happy
unemployment
thank you brian
i like the idea of a random time lord
giving up all their regenerations to the
dock not knowing it was useless
oh that could that would make me sad
actually
they showed brendan being reset with a
chameleon arch-esque headpiece and the
archaeologist's dna so while not
explicitly canon
pretty sure people will make the short
leap okay i guess that would explain it
um from what i've heard scotland will
become the first country in the world to
teach lgbtq plus history as part of the
curriculum
go scotland and
of course they would because scotland is
a country with a unicorn as its official
national animal
so yeah naturally they are
they are super awesome at like
everything
i think i think i might be getting
caught up i feel like i'm almost there
uh there's some very circumstantial
evidence to suggest that joan of arc was
assigned male at birth
huh i'm not i mean
okay i love prawn cocktail crisp they're
great i'm sorry they were disgusting
i mean also understand i don't like
shrimp anyways so maybe that's the
problem
uh i've wanted to donate for a review
request so i hope i can get around to
that soon
i look forward to it once your situation
is sorted i'd recommend fifth doctor big
finish with perry and a new companion
called
uh errormen an egyptian pharaoh huh
they're a fun tardis team interesting
highly recommend monster house i've seen
monster house
it didn't quite work for me you're
watching gravity falls all praise the
triangle
yeah i haven't gotten that far far yet
we're still in season one
what do you love about the greatest
showman i love the energy of the
greatest showman and i love the music
and i also like the messages and i
understand people's problems with the
historical revisionism on it i kind of
did a video on that
i kind of wish they had made it a pt
barnum-esque story but like
named him something original so it was
not literally valorizing someone
more than he probably deserves but i
still like it
i was asleep when we got to buffalo the
first thing i saw was the statue
uh to transgender pulaski
we trans's have our rallies there
uh finally watching gravity falls
hoping you'll love it i'm enjoying it so
far talking sucks yeah it does
it's it's it's a relief to
uh to untuck though at the end at the
end of like a show
i feel like the cue are basically what
raslan was aiming for at the end of time
oh interesting thought
any kind of medicine and surgery isn't
natural exactly
uh the bbc should uh should sell where
is my penny on a t-shirt
it would sound like hotcakes benny
uh scotland also gave us peter capaldi
antenna and mccoy
go scotland
uh 86 minutes i didn't even notice yeah
yeah we've gone a little long on this
one uh
can you do a drunk review on the emoji
movie um
you'd have to pay me for that uh which
is an option
someone did actually commission a drunk
review which i haven't gone to because
i've got all this stuff to get to
first so that is an option
uh if you want to commission reviews so
i've actually caught up on the chat
which
i'm gonna take as a sign to
close out on this one
i i really want to thank
all of you all of you who are in the
chat if you're watching this
archived after it's gone out um
it's just been
[Music]
really wonderful the outpouring of
support of all kinds
um in the wake of having lost
my job it was
way more than i expected and it has done
a lot
to perk up my mood
so thank you and i hope that
you have a wonderful rest of the week
and um i'll see you for the
for the next live stream tracy
oh
you people are awesome
yeah like you're all really awesome but
just remember that
you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved you are the council
i just run the meetings and this
particular meeting
is adjourned